i don't think i'd be the first one to
point out that a lot of doctor who fan
spaces especially on a platform like
youtube have a tendency to go
a bit negative either complaining about
the show itself or complaining about the
fandom
but
let's try and remember
why we love this show
[Applause]
hey there folks so this one's going to
be a little bit different this is going
to be basically a long
conversation between me and another
youtuber in this case jxe who
has done a lot of stuff over the years
but uh at present is probably best known
for making a five-hour long video
talking about
their particular issues with
chris chibnall era of doctor who
i have seen that by the way and if you
feel five hours is too long to sink into
it that's fine but i do feel the need to
defend it insofar as
the reason is five hours long is because
it's actually really thorough and covers
a lot of stuff you know the making of
something like that that much time that
much effort you can tell it still comes
from a place of love
and given that that video seems to still
even now weeks later be in the
conversation and often slagged off i
honestly wanted to just have jay so that
the two of us could talk
about what we love
because after they sunk so much time
into picking apart the things that are
driving them nuts lately
let's all unwind them me you
let's talk about
what we love
in doctor who
so jay thank you so much for coming on
and doing this um i know you pleasure i
thought it would be really fun for us
just to talk
what we love about doctor who whether it
be specific things or the broad things
now i know from the video that you
probably don't remember the first
episode of doctor who you actually saw
absolutely not i think my first um
i mean i have a lot of early memories of
doctor who
but i i think the one that comes first i
couldn't i couldn't confirm this is
definitely the first thing i remember
but i think the first thing i remember
is um
the doctor falling off um the edge of a
pit uh tom baker falling off the edge of
a pit and i think it's the invisible
enemy
it might be um it might be the other one
what's it called it's the something
planet
which is the one where tom baker not the
pirate planet which is the one where tom
baker falls in a big pit
that one
yes that that one unique one because it
only happened the one time
yeah yeah
so
my question then is what's the first one
that you remember loving that like you
would go back to repeatedly remembrance
of the daleks
um as a child i call i was i was very
happy to call seven my favorite doctor
it was based purely on remembrance of
the daleks because that was the only one
i'd watched
um and i i happily called him my
favorite doctor for the whole time never
watching any other any of his other
stories because
if ever i wanted to watch doctor who for
about you know a good year of my life i
would stick on remembrance of the daleks
and i have no idea if my entire family
got sick of it or not most of the things
that i played that much
uh they got sick of but i think i think
my dad especially is such a big
a big fan that he can absolutely just
happily tolerate watching remembrance of
the daleks 50 times
that i mean that is a really good one
that's that's a solid thing and like
because it's always it's always a little
bit nervous when you're looking back to
the stuff you've rewatched a lot when
you were young and then you look at it
with adult eyes and go oh god but no
that's a good one that's a very solid
one
so
so you mentioned definitely at the time
you were saying that number seven was
your favorite so that kind of begs the
obvious question
who is your current
favorite doctor
i mean it really depends on my mood i'm
still i'm still a
a big fan i can really go for seven a
lot of the time but you know
if the vibe is there are some people in
a mansion somewhere and it's raining
outside and someone's been killed i'm
gonna go for some seven
right because he's got a lot of stories
like that especially on audio so see
like the audio and like i've still got
holes in my classic knowledge and the
audio is something that i've i
want to find the time to dig more into
like how extensively into the audios
have you gotten
pretty extensively i haven't listened to
like the full ranges or anything there
are a few ranges i've completed but i've
not gotten extensive knowledge i've not
seen you know i've not seen any of them
i've not heard all of them
um i've not heard you know the whole
monthly range or anything
yeah i've well i've been tackling um big
finish the same way i've been tackling
classic which is jumping absolutely all
over the place because
there's no there's only a select few
things that need to be listened to in a
specific order yeah
which is actually one of the things i
kind of appreciate again
because the way my brain works the idea
of
like going back to the start of the
classic hair and just working
chronologically forward just
just thinking that makes me feel
exhausted
that might be something i'd do one day i
i would i would be incredibly impressed
if you did
um
it's it's funny for me
with my favorite because it's changed
several times
over the years
um i think the first time i did like a
ranking
of them i put 11 at the top and i think
part of that i i can to a certain degree
be prisoner of the moment
um in terms of what is newest
and like because
because when it's new you get that that
fresh feeling to it
that sort of can elevate it it happens
it happens to me with marvel movies
sometimes too like i tend to over rank
uh or the ones that are most recent then
you give me a couple years they'll
probably go down a little bit
um but the other thing with 11 was
we're the same age
uh matt smith and i so it felt it really
felt like oh
that that's like if i was the doctor um
so i think i connected with that for a
bit but at this point
it's capaldi who does not consistently
have the best stories but his
performance and the journey of his
character and how his characterization
changes from series eight to nine to ten
it's something i've absolutely fallen in
love with
um because by the time he wraps up in
series 10 he's exactly who i want him to
be and having done a re-watch now i
enjoyed watching him become
kind of my ideal and i i almost like it
better that he didn't start
that way
and that i i watched him become what i
really love about this character yeah i
totally agree with that i feel like um
it would have been nice if they got to
do that with six as well because that's
what they wanted to do but then they um
they panicked and jumped [ __ ] halfway
through like well thank goodness for the
audios because yeah if it weren't for
the audio adventures both colin baker
and paul mcgann would have absolutely
just been shafted
by
the way the rest of the rest of the
stuff has gone
um
and so
is there
and if you can't think of one i'll take
a couple what are some of the specific
audios that like absolute
top that make you go oh yeah that one
master
um they've done two cold master now the
first one i've not listened to the
second one i have no idea how good it is
but um
master
of the big finish i think has a better
record a better track record with uh the
master than
the new series or the classic series in
my opinion
uh big finish nail the master and
everything i've heard from them
um and master is them absolutely
knocking out the park
that is that is a really good one i i
need to get into the later series of the
war master because i've only heard the
first one
but man it was good
it was i think the second one is the
best
of what i've actually i say that i've
listened to three of them of the five of
those three i think the second one is uh
is the second one is incredible the
other two are brilliant but the second
one just
you know uh stands above us as just
absolutely phenomenal i don't want to
overhype it but wow that's probably my
favorite big finish release this is
going to be a bit of a gushing
essentially we're having so like
potentially we're overhyping anything we
talk about so
um like for me i think
still at this point my favorite audio is
holy terror that's that one's absolutely
brilliant i i love that one and it
it's
it just hits all my all my soft spots
with doctor who and like in general
because we have the sixth doctor being
excellent
because getting to hear
colin baker
actually do really well in this part and
have good material was just wonderful
it has the kind of absurdity that i want
doctor who especially in a medium-like
audio to dip into
so we have frobisher the shape-shifting
talking penguin with a brooklyn accent
and
it's ultimately you know about stories
and how we relate to and the stories we
tell ourselves or the lies that we tell
ourselves which is the kind of meta
nonsense i love
and it's also got my all-time favorite
doctor who related quote which i
actually i had um
somebody sent me a cross stitch of it
well that's that's that's wonderful kind
of behind the chair but um it's the line
that the doctor has
it doesn't matter
towards whom the cruelty is directed the
cruelty itself is wrong
i i love that i will never stop loving
that quote
yeah that's brilliant
i need to re-listen to holy terror have
you heard the um the other one with
phobia bishop the um
it's basically his
it's his not a solo outing but it's it's
he's framed very much as the main
character in it it's i haven't yet it's
like the maltese penguin or something
it's really weird but i do i do
well especially when it comes to big
footage telling me it's weird that's
actually a big selling point
oh yeah
i i don't um i mean it's it's fine when
they just do a
standard action adventure i don't think
it's really a format or even a genre
that lends itself to the audio format
particularly yeah but
you know they're fine they function they
do what they're meant to do
but the most straightforward ones are
usually the ones that i'm like
that that was okay like the ones that
made me go oh dang like i have a hard
time even imagining
making that work visually at least
making it work as well
um
so it yeah it really it really is a
great format when they lean into it
properly
which is one of the reasons that
whenever i see somebody in my comments
being like they should they should have
the folks from big finish start to do
the main show i'm like they really
shouldn't
oh i don't know if i i don't know i
don't know if i
i feel like
if they lean into just because they know
how to use the resources they currently
have i want to i want to test to see if
they can uh translate that to the screen
if they can do stuff
if they um
if in the same way they um
they can lean into the medium that they
are in and create something that could
only be created with what they have
there
because
they've never they've never had a go
doing it officially
well they sort of had
once because you have dalek from series
one which is based off jubilee
which is brilliant
both are brilliant um yeah
and actually it was really fun going and
listening to that after you know knowing
that episode so well and like realizing
how much more there was that story that
they were able to take at like whole
swaths massive themes and stuff and just
boil it down to the dalek bit but then
go back to the original and go oh dang
that's like
one out of four major elements going on
in this thing
jubilee is a story that um
that manages to um i think this is the
mark of a
this is the mark of a really talented
writer is when you have a scene
between two daleks that's an interesting
character scene it's it's the scene that
there's like um loads of animated
recreations of on youtube all of which
are you know in different styles
um and they're all they're all beautiful
um where you've got the damage derelict
that survived the war
talking to the acting supreme dalek
um and it's
such a good scene
i feel like i need to ask this one while
i'm thinking of it i kind i kind of want
to go through
the incarnations of the doctor and see
if he can name me a favor for each one
sure
so
hartnell
with um heartland trout it's gonna be
difficult because i haven't revisited
any of the stuff that they've really
done since i was a kid
um
hartnell especially because
the stuff that i have been revisited is
when it's been animated um which has
mostly been trenton recently yeah
um so i'm not sure i could name your
favorite heart nor story even on audios
because i generally i've no i've not
really listened to any of his audios yet
i i haven't listened to any of those
because i i have a personal like hang up
about um
the impersonation
voices
um and like i i i kind of gave a pass to
david bradley but like in general the
idea of having new actors play old
doctors kind of makes me
uncomfortable
um
i feel like if you do want some then
they do have something where they don't
get impressionists in their um the
companion chronicles where they just
have um
it's it's closer to an audio book than
an audio play but they just have uh the
whole thing read out by one of the
actors okay then
you know like an audiobook oh yeah that
might work okay so
not i think for me i still have a lot of
hurdle i haven't seen i think it's
currently
uh dalek invasion of earth for me for
that one i'm watching that very soon
excellent what about
trouton uh trouton i do want to go for
power of the daleks you know it's one of
the ones that we visited recently and i
preferred it to the other ones i
revisited recently i did think it was
really good
for me with him it's it's tombs of the
cybermen
accepting how many massively problematic
elements in that story there are like i
will not defend any of them
but it it has all of the things i love
about trout in that his
his pretending to be
stupid when in fact he's figuring out
what's going on his being a little bit
snide his being legitimate panicky and i
love the interactions he has with jamie
and victoria and that there it's like
the essence of what i love about him
our lives are different to
anybody else's that's the exciting thing
uh even though there's some elements
going on around him i'm like
he is brilliant in this story yeah
and the side men are brilliant in that
story as well yeah
yeah they are it's
you really have to focus to understand
the freaking voice but
[Music]
oh it's one of my favorite voices
that's this that's some that voice like
just that voice to the side man is one
to be fair i think i would be able to
say i think is brilliant even if i
hadn't revisited recently which i have
um
because just it made such an impression
on me as a child
that i remember it very clearly
and i'm watching again i did remember it
very clearly and you know it was just um
it was going through all of these things
that i
knew were going to happen which isn't
isn't always the case when your grief is
something that you've not seen for like
10 years uh so
pertly
this is a lot of solid choices
um
i recently revisited um pertwee's
derelict stories and wasn't particularly
sold on on any of them
unfortunately
um
but i do so as even though i wasn't sold
on them i still have such a soft spot
for death to the daleks
it's like i don't think this is good i
just like watching it
you know there's nothing wrong with that
of course of course and like
my favorite for him is like
i
people don't tell me it's bad but i do
get kind of sideways looks like really
that one and for me it's time warrior
really that one
that's yeah that yeah that's the one
it's it's a combination of i i
love how fully formed the santarans are
in their very first appearance
no i'm sorry i just got i was thinking
of time monster ah
okay so yes that would be a more that
would be more
no uh so this one very first appearance
of the santarans i love how fully formed
they are in that first appearance of
sarah jane smith also one of her better
because they weren't devolving her into
being screamy and panicky like they
would do later
um and i like
you'll find with me i i could be a
sucker for like when something has some
of my favorite moments i can forgive a
lot of what's what else might be going
on and it has my favorite line from
pertuy where sarah jane asked him you're
serious aren't you about what i do yes
not necessarily the way i do it
that's um i think that's that's a that's
a definitive quote from the doctor
really it's one of the most fundamental
descriptions of the character delivered
so quickly
it it really it's it's
it is one sentence with a comma in and
it's like yep that that sums it up right
there that's him yeah that's the guy
um so
fourth doctor tom baker
so many good choices
this is a long stretch of time
oh yeah i mean there's some
and it's so much of it is just brilliant
um
i have a very i have a soft spot for uh
seeds of
doom
yes
it's seeds of doom because what is seeds
of death was second doctor
they got that you know it worked
that see for me and this is
for for me my favorite out of the fourth
doctor is actually
currently my favorite classic hero story
at all
um and that's uh city of death
oh yeah
you know what i probably named
seeds of doom because i'd forgotten
about city of death in the moment i was
thinking
uh city of death is the ghosty one that
i show people to figure out if they will
have any interest in you know watching
any more classic who yeah it's like this
is
this this is just it refined and done to
perfection
yeah it kind of it works for that
because like you could show people that
when like okay it won't always be this
good but the things that are good in
this are what are good about the whole
thing oh yeah yeah
and i mean i've like i loved douglas
adams since middle school so i was i was
kind of gonna be an easy mark for that
one anyway because it's
it's very douglas adams
douglas adams is brilliant oh man i
realized i i think probably
um i was going to say reread honestly
re-listen to the audiobook the version
narrated by him but i've probably
re-listened to the first three uh
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxies on
audiobook probably
10 times a piece at this point
i i i've i'm in a similar boat i've
i've listened to them a lot um i
couldn't tell you how many times but
yeah
they are brilliant
uh so this next one i don't know about
for you but for me this next one's
actually really tough and that's fifth
doctor peter davison
caves
caves vandrazani i mean
that's kind of where i'm at too but it's
by default because i
i have a really hard time connecting
with his doctor
caves is brilliant i i do have a hard
time connecting with him as well but i
do like him as a character i don't
really i don't really connect with him
but i like seeing what he does
um and i i guess um
it is the default choice i guess if i
want to make um
a less default choice i can go for
aquitaine which is
i'm not sure if we're doing audios or
not but i mean i'm injecting them into
the conversation we're get we're getting
to the sixth doctor we're gonna have to
include audios
i know i like revelation
i haven't re-watched that one yet but
like my memory of watching it for the
first time is like is the doctor ever
going to actually matter to this story
and then getting to the end and going no
no he did not
yeah
he literally just walks in at the end
and takes credit
that's a very quintessential early sex
move
true it's not out of character it just
made for a real frustrating story for me
but anyway we were still on five um
[Music]
so aquitaine that's uh is that from the
monthly range or it is for me aquitaine
is just sort of um
it's just refined who it doesn't do
anything it's it's the sort of strange
middle it's weird as well because um
it's one that they absolutely could do
on tv in fact it almost feels like it's
working in the limitations of like
a 1980s
doctor who uh
team who are fully aware of the the
budget they have because it's all set in
corridors that um are canonically reused
at different points within the story
um but with different set dressing
it's like oh it's the same
there's like literally moments where
they figure out no this isn't a
different corridor this is the same
corridor
like
um that's kind of adorable actually it
is it is and the whole thing the whole
story takes place in this um in this
place
um
so yeah it could it would work
brilliantly on tv but um
it's got these it's got
um a very small but very uh distinctive
and interesting side cut caster side
characters
and it's got just a
fun romp of a story
um and it's like
in the same way that city of death is
the familiar elements you know done to
perfection that's what aquitaine is as
well i wouldn't put it on the same i
wouldn't want to you know send any of
city of death to fans to it saying this
is the same city of death
but it is brilliant
very cool i might have to check that one
out because i i'm i'm still looking for
something that really gets me to click
with the with the fifth doctor but like
i will not argue caves of anger zany is
really good i mean i guess um
if you're looking for something to to
click with him
he's not like the selling element of the
story for me you know he's there and
he's good in it you know
but
it's more like just a cumulative effect
of the whole story you know is is great
um i don't i don't i don't come out of
that story thinking about how good the
doctor was in it i come out of that
story just thinking yeah that was just
thoroughly great the whole way through
the highlight is um there's a side
character called ha greaves who was a
robot butler
um he's the highlight and if anyone
comes out with a different highlight i
will
go if anyone comes out saying that
something else was the highlight i will
be thinking
how cruz has got to be second right you
know
very good so
colin baker
i've got a soft spot for him i
i have one now thanks to the audios
prior to that like i and i didn't it's
not that i blamed him
you know for
what was going on with he was clearly
trying his best oh yeah yeah
um but yeah like i already spilled i
already showed my hand on this one um
because holy terror
i absolutely love
um but but for you if you had to pick
one
i'm trying to think because i know there
are a lot um masters of earth is
springing to mind but i i know it's not
my favorite i know it's masters of earth
is just this sort of
again it's just another solid doctor who
story i wouldn't put on the same level
as aquitaine but it was just you know
you listen to it and you get to the end
of it and you think that was a good
doctor who story
and that's all it was you know
like sometimes that's what you want it's
okay to have comfort food i wanna it is
it is i wanna i'm just gonna do a cheeky
google of it of six doctor audios
and see if any come up that that i'm
that
i'm gonna kick myself for forgetting
about because they will oh davros is
brilliant jubilee is there as well how
could i forget about jubilee
i've got to say jubilee is brilliant i
need to re-listen to that one to be fair
it really i'd need to re-listen to a lot
of them but i i kind of hold off
realistically like you've got so many
you haven't even heard in the first
place yet what are you doing
re-listening to stuff um
so
seventh doctor sylvester mccoy
am i gonna say master again um
i could
um i'm also a big fan of um
and just anywhere um anyone any of them
where he's solving a murder mystery
um he that's like he excels in that
um
he he
he is at his peak when he's
um sitting and listening to other people
talk and thinking and what he says after
he's done that thinking is going to be
brilliant
like that's um
that's where he excels
i'm i'm on the time scales now and i've
just got i mean
another part of what i love about
um
seven is like he just had a fantastic
companion pairing with ace oh he did
yeah and like that can do a lot and i've
said in the past i think that's part of
why i have a hard time connecting with
five
is it doesn't feel like he has a
definitive companion none of them ever
stuck around long enough and there was
always so many at a time i don't have a
core relationship to like suss him out
on
um
but it's
some of the stuff i really love from
classic like i love
uh second doctor and jamie
um i love that dynamic and i love
uh seventh doctor and ace and something
about having a really good
companion dynamic can do a lot to
elevate the doctor in general now i am
gonna be kind of a basic [ __ ] and say
remembrance of the daleks four
four seven that's very fair
i've just got i've just been reminded of
um of damaged goods which weirdly enough
is one without ace in it damage damage
goods has his uh his companions from the
target novels in it the target novels
the virgin novels okay um
and yeah big finish did a thing where
they adapted loads of the the seventh
doctor novels for a while and there was
some really good stuff in there i wanted
to get them all and listen to the mortar
in order and then i realized that big
finish hadn't adapted a lot of the
significant novels so i thought that
seems kind of pointless to do them in
order if there are going to be gaps
um
so i've just been i've just been
listening to them
as i get them and they are all
so far the ones i've heard are all
brilliant nice
nice
so um
paul mcgann i'm gonna make a leap and
assume it's not the movie
honestly he's brilliant in the movie
it's just everything else about the
movie but like if you want to judge him
as a character the movie he is actually
he is actually really good he nails the
part immediately
yeah but
yeah the the rest of it
but i could just got to give the script
credit in the movie as well because it's
it's a good script for the doctor he he
says all the right things
i mean the other thing i'll give the
movie credit for having rewatched it a
couple years ago like it actually looks
pretty good it does you can tell the
production value went up significantly
the movie is weird watching the movie
now i guess is weird to me
because
knew who
feels
totally so much more like the movie than
it feels like classical like you're
watching the scene of um
of of the doctor and and grace like
shimmy down the side of a building on
like a hose
hose is it a hose that they do
i can't even it's either it might be a
drain pipe
something like that and you're just
watching it thinking this isn't this is
a proto-noohoo scene and the vortex as
well they've got for the intro yeah a
bit who knew who
borrows so much from the film
new who is almost
new who is a sequel to the film more
than more so than it is to classic who
in a lot of ways which is bizarre to me
because it did so poorly i well i don't
think that's intentional i suspect that
that happened just because of attempting
to modernize the concept is going to
make it feel more like the thing that
was done after time to feel more
modernized
than the stuff that frankly by the time
we got to the 80s with doctor who was
very deliberately outdated in its
presentation and how it went about
things so
i i i think that's coincidental but
you're not wrong
it could very much be coincidental but
even even so i'm surprised they didn't
avoid doing the same things that the
movie did with um do you felt i don't
know what its reputation was like in
2005. i
i think it was pretty bad
but um i don't i don't know what kind of
reputation it had other than mcgahn
himself i don't think he's ever had a
good reputation
yeah
yeah i mean
um and i know that mcgahn had a bad
reputation back in the day
people um he i've heard him think saying
interviews that he used to go to cons
but he got abused from people where oh
no they would yeah where they would say
you know they'd call him a waste of a
doctor and he stopped going uh something
like that i remember him saying that he
got called a waste of a doctor at
conventions
um
so
yeah
paul
but um
i know that he i know that the movie
must have had a pretty poor reputation
at least in some circles to get that
kind of stuff going on but thankfully
we have big fingers so d do you have a
pick um
i wanna i always wanna just say like the
full series like the cumulative effect
of the full series between him and lucy
it's it's weird picking out individual
stories from those
because they are very much a
a journey from
the beginning to the end so that's
that's starting with blood of the daleks
and starting with blood
and ending with um to the death i think
is the last one
if i had to pick an individual story it
would be the red lady i think and like i
feel like times of midnight is the
might be the easy answer uh and it is
really good folks who know big finish
would have realized i'm naming a lot of
uh robert sherman
written audios he just writes really
good ones he does that's you you can't
blame someone for getting into big
finish by binging all the robert sherman
once yeah no you really can't but
honestly
if i'm if i'm gonna go by what do i go
back to like when i want an eighth
doctor fix
i go back to nine to the doctor honestly
that short in seven minutes just
watching him and like in getting to see
him like he's wonderful on audio but
getting to see him
own
that part for seven solid minutes i'm
like this is gold
it's another one where i say he's
brilliant in it but i don't like the
story at all i like the honest thing is
is
be i think i get away with this in my
head because it's so short that like i
just focus on his interactions and yeah
him as a character like i don't tend to
think too much about it's oh it's
overall plot relevance to the franchise
continuity as a whole and in and of
itself it doesn't have much of a plot
yeah and so like i i just zero in on him
and love every second of it it's broadly
speaking like the fact that it doesn't
have a plot is why i'm like
this is this is the ending for him this
is this is the ending he got in seven
minutes of
oops i like watching it but i don't like
that it exists if that makes sense i
wish that yeah no i get that that does
make there are some things that you
could be like i enjoyed this but the the
what it means that it is a thing
is an issue i would much rather if um if
he was just a day of the doctor instead
or if they'd done just you know
and a different 10-minute adventure with
him where he would ends where he leaves
and he's fine
so
if we're going incarnation order
do you have a pick for the war master
i'm sorry war doctor yeah i definitely
have a pick for the war master but um i
don't think i do have a pick for the
award for the war doctor i listened to
his box sets a long time ago
and
that meant the memory of doing that has
blended all into just sort of
audio soup where i can't pick out the
details of any individual story i only i
only i can't tell you how far actually i
got through them
um
it's not a comment on on them i remember
enjoying them at the time but i just
didn't make much of an impression i
suppose i i think i honestly did myself
a massive disservice by listening to the
first war master box set first before
doing the war doctor and i think it
completely skewed my expectations
because the war doctor i've only done
the first box set so far is
fine but the war master blew me away and
i think i had skewed expectations i
i guess by
default i'm gonna say day of the doctor
which again is is a very mixed bag for
me because there's certain aspects of it
i'm like what are we doing then there's
other parts of it that i do think are
legitimately really good
um
unfortunately i wouldn't even really put
him at the top of the list of what is
good about day of the doctor
that's strange because i think he's i
think he's the standout bit of it
i think i think the thing is i i feel
like he doesn't get the proper focus
given that it's really his only proper
outing and i kind of wanted it to be
much more about him
than it
actually is and that's nothing against
john hurt john hurt's good and
everything i think i think the day of
the doctor is just a warning don't
introduce a doctor in a multi-doctor
story and make it also be his only story
on on tv
yeah
i mean that's it's unfortunate how that
kind of panned out but we'll move on so
ninth doctor
who we now are starting to get audios
from which i haven't gotten to yet but
christopher eccleston it's all of it
it's just it's
i was picking up that vibe from you uh
from that video
it's this um it's this i mean that's the
whole thing is this one solid journey
from beginning to end that works i think
best as a whole
and it's just it's brilliant
it's it's a brilliant series of
television i'm trying to pick one i am
i'm struggling
well if you're struggling i i can give
you mine it's the empty child and the
doctor dances for me on that one yeah i
have to agree actually it just has so
much like eccleston is giving some of
his best most impassioned stuff i found
the concept of the empty child to be
wonderfully freaky it really did creep
the heck out of me
um and we get introduced to
jack harkness we have the everybody
lives moment like this is oh
this this is all the stuff i love about
when he when he was in the part
because it's um it hits the emotion it
hits with all the emotional beats it
hits it could have been the series
finale to what he he gets it has all you
know it would be a great conclu not not
a conclusion to his arc you know he'd
still be a person after it and he is and
he keeps growing but
it would be a great book end to it to a
to the arc that you see him go through
in his first series so if you know if
they did have a shorter series or if
they wanted to you know prolong his
journey over multiple series and maybe
have parting of the ways be the series 2
finale or something
the empty child
would be
or i guess the doctor dances
would be a brilliant finale but it's
sort of
also it's only because of the emotional
beats and i feel like people are in it
for the plot would sort of feel a bit
uh
left out yeah i guess i guess so but
like emotionally i feel like the series
up to that point was building to the
everybody lives
yeah exactly joy
that he has in that moment
just the joy the joy he feels getting to
save everyone is what
is what his entire run is about really
yeah
that's a great one so
uh i think still usually considered the
fan favorite and the one i get i get
crap for not loving as much as everybody
else uh david tennant 10th doctor i
think i you know i still i understand
exactly where you're coming from i think
i see him as just another doctor who was
good but for highlights
i don't know i'm i'm i'm struggling to
like you know
i
generally my brain struggles with
specific recall from long lists
this is i'm just gonna have to click him
on the uh on the time scales again i'll
let you do that i i flip back and forth
between the library two-parter and
midnight those are both
i can't i can't blame anyone for either
those picks they're both absolutely
brilliant i've also got my nostalgic
favorite which i can't defend quite as
much but that's the
the impossible planet in the satan pit
because catching part of that on tv when
i was on my honeymoon in london was what
got me to
go yeah i need to be into this show i
don't feel like i don't feel like it's
i feel like that's a very defensible
pick um
i think that's a very solid story
there's like
i guess like i don't know what i think
the biggest issue i could see someone
having with it would be
that it's solved by luck
i mean part of it's that i think i think
overall it and this is not an uncommon
thing with the two parties in the modern
era the the setup is stronger than the
payoff
i i do feel that's the case that i don't
think that's the case with the library
two-parter personally but i do feel that
a little bit in the impossible planet
and the satan pit
i mean like i under i understand i i get
exactly what you mean but to me i'm just
like
yeah but that's just because the setup
is so brilliant like it really yeah it
really really is um you've named all the
the brilliant ones i guess um beat you
to it oh the family flirt is up there as
well oh yeah
yeah because it's not really an outing
for him is it
no it's not but it's just so
it's so good and it's funny because you
get a very complete character
in john smith
and it should feel triumphant when the
doctor comes back at the end and for
about
half a minute it does
until it's terrifying yeah and until
you're like oh
john smith is gone
yeah that's the story that really has it
out for
the doctor and the things that he'll do
in fact i did say it's not really an
outing for it but those though the brief
time he is in it he gets a hell of an
outing yeah
i i
really appreciate the
little
um the little the little the little
talking to he's given at the end where
um i've forgotten her name says to him
um just nurse redfern is that i'll trust
you
um
just says says to him if um if you
hadn't chosen this place on a whim would
anyone have died
um and him him getting that at the end
of the story
just just the time that he does have as
himself as a full outing for him that
you might it's a full exploration of his
character that you might it might take
you know another story the whole two
parts to give
and you know the moment that i actually
like that's part of that same
interaction between the two of them that
i feel is particularly telling
especially for this incarnation of the
doctor
who is a bit higher on himself
than the doctor is sometimes the doctor
can be confident he's not always
egotistical
ten is a bit um but there's something
about that moment where she says to him
could you change back
yes
no
and again i feel like it it speaks a lot
about this particular incarnation
so
11th doctor matt smith i like what they
were going for no um i do i do really
like what they were going for in part
and i don't another in others but
um i do think he shines a lot i think he
really shines in the god complex
that that's a good i feel like that's an
underappreciated episode honestly it um
it even
it even
frustrates me with the stuff that it
sort of shows me could be in this era
and then isn't is absent for a lot of
the rest of it
um because it is just really good the
character that it introduces is sort of
a one-off episode one-off
pseudo-companion for the episode i can't
remember her name
yeah i can't i know who you mean though
the she's the medical student i mean she
sort of played up as this perfect
companion who the doctor would like to
bring with him
um which might as well start the the
death clock over her head yeah yeah yeah
some people say that she'd be like too
perfect of a companion but i don't know
if there is such a thing you know as in
like she takes all the boxes that the
doctor would want
um
but the thing about her is
she contrasts
so much the women that moffat usually
writes
um
she's sort of
quiet and reserved but still
um
strong and and
um sure of herself you know all the
women that um
that my fat rights are generally
um if they have an idea or an impulse
the whole room knows
he
yeah he doesn't seem to understand that
not all women are extreme extroverts i
feel like it's just an archetype that he
got comfortable writing far too
comfortable writing
um
and
so you know then you've got amy clara
and river
yeah yeah faster as well
i mean and arguably missy who i love uh
yeah
and it's kind of frustrating because the
thing is like i actually really like
that archetype but when somebody points
that out i'm like
yeah he did overuse that yeah
um and
that that medical student is the
companion that i wanted matt smith's
doctor to have for at least a season
because it would have been such a
different dynamic but i'll settle for
the one episode
um so i
this is another one where i have two i
go back and forth between and which one
i say kind of depends on the on the day
you ask me
i go back and forth between vincent and
the doctor
and the 11th hour because like the 11th
hour
i think i am still amazed at how much
that accomplishes yeah as efficiently as
it does
in what 50 minutes
it's life 45 it is astonishingly
um succinct and
efficient in what it's doing while still
being incredibly entertaining like it is
cramming so much in
as far as
giving us a sense of this new giving us
a very strong sense of this new doctor
and who he is
introducing a an atypical companion with
an atypical starting relationship with
the doctor
um you know and and
sort of serving almost as a soft reboot
and having to re-establish all the
basics in case anybody's jumping on for
the first time with this and also
telling a fun story on top of that i'm
like
like hats off to cramming all that in
holy cow i wish honestly i wish the the
stuff from 11th hour was um
like you know the setups from the 11th
hour used more i want more
i want more of that dynamic between amy
and the doctor going forward where
um
he is the imaginary friend she had as a
little girl
um i i want to see that you know i want
to see that expanded upon and and and
just talked about um as an aspect of
their friendship more often yeah it's
brilliant and it would have been but
like i really loved that what it meant
was
even though she is like kind of getting
to know him properly for the first time
she's already fed up with him and done
with his crap because
because he left her alone as a kid
and another thing just
eleventh hour is all of the this this
can be like used as both like um as both
sort of a uh
a compliment to a an episode or
um like
the opposite
but
i mean it in all the best ways when i
say this is an episode that moffat wrote
like in his head as a kid and refined
and like it's so clearly
it's so clearly the thing that he wanted
to do for ages and he's finally got to
do it
it's all the beats it's very it's very
determined it knows exactly what it
wants to do and it does it very well
yeah and with vincent and the doctor
it's just such a well-delivered
emotional
story and i think definitely one of the
more thorough and respectful looks at
depression and i think part of the
reason it works is because it is dealing
with depression
both directly and
metaphorically
because doing i i think you actually
have more pitfalls just doing one or the
other
because there's a lot of trope pitfalls
with standard depictions of depression
and there's a lot of um
analytical pitfalls about trying to deal
with it in a more metaphorical
sense but i think
having them sort of happen in tandem the
way that it does
uh it sort of enables the the strengths
of showing it directly but also
allowing for a more interpretive take on
it to kind of buoy each other in a way
in a way that i'm not sure
too many other shows could have pulled
off vincent dr is just
it's just i know it's just like it's
pretty i don't know that's the word i
want to use for it it's this like this
is pretty
episode elephant
episode of television
um
where
and it shouldn't be pretty because of
what it's about but i do think it is
well i i actually think that's kind of
really important to it because there's
there's the
perception or i don't even know if it's
a perception but there's definitely a
standard in the depiction of depression
that like everything is gray and
lifeless and like no
he sees the world vibrantly
with you know all these colors and and
there is light and light yeah
but that doesn't mean he's not depressed
yeah that's you're right that's that's
the whole point of the story really
i mean that's that's i feel like i feel
like i just missed that you know well
that's what i think is great about
the pile of good things
good things
don't always
soften the bad things but vice versa the
bad things don't necessarily spoil the
good things will make them unimportant
just because
ultimately the the darkness overtook him
doesn't mean that the good things
weren't good and that it wasn't worth
bringing some of that to his life
and
so i there's just way more nuance in it
than the very
blunt hammer that depression tends to
get depicted with in a lot of media
yeah
yeah definitely it's it's one that's
just sort of
i'm very happy exists
so
peter capaldi 12th doctor
i'm still i'm still a stickler for
listen
i know that's sort of a
the sort of like the that's the normie
choice exactly when it came the
listening was getting the most
appreciation exactly when it came out
and then no one really
noticed it anymore after that i still
it's still a thoroughly engaging watch
and it is um
it's just interesting it's just it's
this episode of doctor who that sort of
goes we can fill these 45 minutes
however we like you don't get to tell us
no you get to tell us not to do this i
mean especially when they've got peter
capaldi holding the scene it's like does
this make any sense no but look at him
go
it's like
it it throws out all like elements of
conventional plot structure
it just sort of delivers the information
that it needs to within the time it has
so that you can understand what happens
in it
um
and
i respect that as just this bizarre 45
minutes of television
that do a thing
and they do it pretty well there's stuff
about the upside i don't like but it is
it's it's an episode that i i
wish i liked more than i do but it and
it is one of those where some of the
continuity implications of it
uh niggle and annoy me yeah but there is
a lot of really strong stuff in that one
capaldi's so weird for me because he is
currently my favorite doctor
and
yet aren't that many episodes or stories
that he had that i had that i love
without reservation
it's it's like watching your favorite
actor in movies that that aren't good
enough for them is is how i feel like
i'm watching them a lot of times you do
get a lot of that from him yeah that
having been said for a long time
it was heaven sent
and heaven sent is still really up there
for me
but at this point following the re-watch
and
seeing how it caps off that arc that i
brought up before that i love so much i
i have to go with the dr falls
and yeah his especially his
confrontation with the master and missy
and his summation
of why
he does it
i do what i do because it's right
because it's decent
and above all it's kind
i just i i love that
he's great in it
he is
he's always he's a doctor who's always
sort of the best part of his own stories
if he's work you know whether he's
working with something that's just you
know
he's i've not really watched it i assume
he's the best part of kill the moon but
you know from kill the moon to heaven
yeah he's always the best part of his
own story yes he is the best part of
kill he has some great moments he's got
this great moment early on with that
where he's just playing with the yo-yo
and no one notices he's like this
shouldn't be working on moon gravity and
you like you realize he's been he's his
brain has been ticking away while
everyone else is just trying to figure
out where they even are
so yeah but oh god oh man that one i
might do
i like thin ice a lot
um thin ice went up a lot in my
estimation on a re-watch oh yeah thin
ice
um
i find that happens with all of the
early episodes that just sort of um
early series episodes like smith and
jones they just thought jones is
brilliant smith and jones is banger like
the the thing about these episodes is
you just we watch them for the first
time and because they're just sort of
these like
essential they feel like very
[Music]
normal doctor who they feel like you get
to the end of them and you think yes i
have just watched doctor who and that's
what you feel right
um
but you another thing because they're
they're early season stuff
they're more con they're not concerned
with you know delivering the payoffs of
like you know we don't know these
characters well enough to give them
something like father's day or amy's
choice yet yeah um you're still learning
who they are but when you
when you appreciate that what it's doing
is teaching you who they are then going
back and watching smith and jones or
thin ice you're like wow this does a
really good job at that yeah all the
characterization all the character
interactions between bill and and and
the doctor in thin ice are brilliant
i i still and i for some reason i'd
forgotten this but when i went back and
rewatched it i was
bowled over by her reaction when well
first of all
they let a kid die
okay
and like treated it seriously that's
like my biggest beef with uh school
reunion which is an episode i otherwise
liked but they very casually kill a
miner in the cold open and i kind of
hate that um but here it's given weight
and her reaction to basically kind of
run away like need to just find her
breath and then to confront him
incredibly directly
tell me how many people you've seen died
i don't know
how many before you lost count and not
letting him weasel his way out of these
questions that's exactly what it is when
you see the doctor it's a story where he
has to
essentially get someone to understand
i have lived a very long time through a
lot of hard stuff i am used to death
um
but i still have
my own
morals and principles and ideals and i
haven't let them die just because i've
seen
all of this horrible stuff and had to be
involved in loads of horrible stuff
and it's it just does that that's that's
what it does and it does it really well
and as a bonus a racist gets punched in
the face so yeah that's always fun yeah
you can't go wrong with that so
i have a i have a suspicion i already
know what your answer is going to be and
i'm wondering how many asterisks sees
you're going to put on it
but uh jody whittaker
13th doctor
the whole time that's right
i knew i knew it was going to be that
one
it's just the one that nails the
character writing i don't um
the biggest asterisk i would put on it
is that i don't like i like that the
doctor takes control at the end and
makes puts her foot down and says this
is the decision we're making because
sometimes this team structure isn't flat
it's mountainous with me at the summit
in the stratosphere alone
i am even fine with the decision she
makes but what i don't like is the
explanation of why she makes the
decision she makes
which is
um
i think i think it misses the mark of
just what you know the doctor
believes or what it's you know
even good to believe really is that no
he's not we're not saving him over the
while risking the lives of everyone else
because he's a important historical
writer and he's he's the one of the
great men who shaped history that's not
why he's important the important reason
to save him is because you can strive to
save him and everyone else and you don't
have to give up uh you don't have to you
know the explanation i wanted to give i
want them to give is yeah we're gonna
save him
because i think there's still i think
we can try to do whatever we can try to
save everyone we don't have to sacrifice
him we you know we don't have to
sacrifice him we can just try harder and
do both like that is a really good
episode and i got to with this
right before everything shut down and
went to hell but i got to see that
premiere
in a crowded hall at gallifrey one
um
and that was a really amazing viewing
experience to be with
a crowd that wanted nothing but to love
every second of it and pretty much did
yeah that must have been amazing it was
so much of the episode is brilliant i
think ashard is a standout villain not
just for his era but for doctor who he's
great oh yeah in that episode
um yeah unfortunately like he doesn't
pan out as much but and i i kind of feel
the same about the silence i actually
love
the initial introduction episodes of the
silence yeah um yeah but they don't pan
out
to watch by the end but like that
those first appearances is the same with
a shot like ah yeah
yeah
it's brilliant for you know for the 20
minutes is in in haunting and then
and then in the subsequent two episodes
he's there and then he dies um so for me
and like i i
i know i get pushback on this one and
but like i will i will explain as best i
can for me 13th doctor episode that i
unabashedly love
is can you hear me
and i love it
for the thematics and the thoroughness
of them
um what i will absolutely grant is if
you're mainly here to get good
characterization and to see these
characters progress and stuff like that
it doesn't do that particularly well
but
with the way that it's talking about
depression i don't think as well as
vincent and the doctor but the way that
it is and the way these two godlike
beings kind of embody depression and
what they do is make is take planets and
make these people battle themselves
which is what mental illness does to a
lot of people it puts you at war with
yourself
and
touching on the different ways that that
can manifest with yaz and with ryan's
friend
and
also the fact that while they get
defeated at the end they don't get
killed they can only be captured they
can only be contained
which leaves the implication they can't
be freed again
when i look at it from a thematic level
contained within the episode if you're
trying to stretch out the thematics of
the series as a whole no
not so much but within the episode i
really adored the way that those themes
were woven into the narrative
um again having seen your video and
knowing some of your issues with it i
have no counter to any of them it's just
that
the things that i loved about that i
love so much i'm i'm prepared to be okay
with other stuff well yeah and i don't
ever set out with my criticism to take
something that someone got from
something away from them but when people
just you know
read a moral from a story or
or you know whatever from have an
interpretation that's not you know
something that i want to argue
well like and here's the other thing and
i'm and i i'm going to defend
that moment that everybody hates
um
at the end between graham and the doctor
again mostly within the confines of the
episode less within you know if you have
overall issues with this
characterization or inconsistencies or
whatever but within the confines of the
episode
i actually really like that interaction
i should say a reassuring thing now
shouldn't i i'm still quite socially
awkward i'm just gonna subtly walk
towards the console in a minute i'll
think of something that i should have
said it might have been helpful
because it doesn't it didn't read to me
like her brushing him off
because she's socially awkward it
actually read to me
as her letting him in on something that
she would normally just have done
like
the way that she's characterized in this
episode like she would have been awkward
and not known what to say and would have
gone over and fiddled with stuff and
stalled for time and then said something
later
and she's still going to do that because
that's who she is but she's going to let
him in and be like
i'm this is what i'm doing going to
process and help the best that i can
these are the steps i'm going to take
and
given how honestly closed off and not
very open she is with the companions
despite them being called the fam
it actually felt like one of the more
honest moments she had with a companion
and i it felt
despite the surface level of looking
like it was brushed off it actually felt
like a moment of vulnerability to me
i find it hard to tell
when
she's supposed to be being closed off in
in the show
because it can be read like the fact
that i have to preface this with my read
on it kind of doesn't make a sense that
it's not entirely clear necessarily but
that was the read that i took and kind
of why i
was not only okay with the moment i
actually really liked it i think it's
like her characterization is so
confused in a lot of
a lot of the episodes a lot of the a lot
of the scenes that i wanted to talk
about for 13's characterization in my
video i ended up just sort of scrapping
because i sort of had to go
all i can really say about this scene is
that these are some words that she said
and they could have meant a lot of
things
i'm not sure because the context of the
rest of the story
doesn't support any one read clearly
enough for me to be able to talk about
the read that i think it isn't why uh
and what effect that read has on the
story
yeah i mean like that's part of why i'm
able to love this episode is i love my
read of this episode yeah um so and and
being kind of a death of the author type
anyway i'm very comfortable doing that
and even if somebody were to tell me
that you know the chimney or whoever the
the writer of that actual scribbles came
out later and said no it's actually
about this i would go
i don't care i like my reading yeah i
mean that's that's what i do as well um
i mean
i have a lot of personal reads about
doctor who the uh
that i don't really care what the
writers think this is how i see these
characters
so um
obviously with with how long we've just
spent going through favorite doctor
stories we're not going to go through
every doctor and pick out favorite
campaigns for each but overall
some of your favorite companions
martha bill
sarah lucy
and for clarification for folks mostly
familiar with the tv show that's the uh
that's the companion from the big finish
that yeah
that's the eighth doctor's uh
one of his audio companions actually um
i like uh charlie as well who is his
first audio companion
lucy i haven't gotten to i have heard
charlie and i do like her
i you know i like joe as well
um really
yeah joe's great i like joe um i don't
know if i'm i don't know if it's just my
impression of her as inseparable from my
impression of katie manning who's just
genuinely a treasure on the on earth you
know and that's valid
yeah but like i i can't separate my
impression of joe from my impression of
katie manning and kate manning is just
she radiates joy like that's just who
she is and you know what um when she was
brought back in the sarah jane
adventures
she
had the same energy that um
that katie manning has now so i do feel
there is some overlap between the
character and the actor there i don't
know how much but quite possibly so like
i mentioned some of my favorites already
um so like jamie with the second doctor
which another thing that happened at
gallifrey one uh was fraser hines was
there he shared a story we shared a
number of stories but the one i really
remember is uh when he was talking about
filming tombs of the cybermen
there's that moment where um they're
getting ready to go in
and the doctrine jamie reached to take
victoria's hand to reassure her take a
few steps realize they have each other's
hands and then are like ah come on let's
go jordan
come on victoria
and that was not written in the script
that was improvised they just did that
oh that's lovely i love you enjoy that
moment that's that's a great moment and
i like jamie because jamie has you know
he's he's just got such a contrasting
energy
um
to trouton's doctor that i think they
have great chemistry there are times
that i love sarah jane it basically
seems to depend on who's writing her
yeah
when when i love her i really love her
but there are other times where i'm like
oh for god's sake who wrote this one
she
she's brilliant when she's capable and
she's brilliant when she's just sort of
got this um
you know
space mom energy
yeah
um although speaking of ones who have
contrasting energy to the doctor they're
with i actually and thank the audios for
this one i really like evelyn smythe
oh yeah she's brilliant she's perfect
because
and and you buy it with her as a
character with with her age and her
level of experience and her level of
knowledge that she is the one willing to
actually tell the sixth doctor to shut
up
because it really that was one of the
things that was really hard about
watching
his eras is the companions perry
especially just seemed so scared of him
perry is the companion that you could
most accurately describe as the doctor's
victim
it just feels
it feels like a
it felt like an abusive relationship
like he was afraid to say the wrong
thing because he might hit her that was
the vibe
and so then in the audios to pair him
with this older woman who's just gonna
look at him and go shut up you're being
an idiot i'm like oh thank you this this
was the counterbalance to his brashness
that i needed yeah and
it's
it's what he needed for his arc
is to be told what he needed for his ark
was to be told to shut up by someone he
has respect for it's a choice that makes
sense pairing him with her
in every way um
it's just yeah that's the thing they
should have done and they did it and
they did it brilliantly like her worst
outings are things where she doesn't get
enough to do you know yeah
yeah
like
don't under utilize her she's great yeah
i was listening to the apocalypse
element recently
which is great i love the apocalypse
outlet just because it takes me back to
a time when it felt like the universe of
doctor who had a clear
state and that that state could be
changed by events that happened in it
um whereas now it's sort of a bit more
uh since the moffat era i think it's a
bit messy and hard to keep track of
but i do like i do like stories that
have sort of implications on a on the on
the level of this is going to change the
world the stories are in an apocalypse
element is
it have you heard it because i'm trying
to i haven't heard that one
it's um
it's it's one that um
really feels like a step from a to b in
a way that you can't really have anymore
with
long-term established doctor who stuff
um it's something that because it's it's
it's not a spoiler the dialects are in
it they're they're on the cover you know
this like you know this if you're
listening to it they they don't know how
to surprise us with daleks they have
given up trying um
but um
it's a story that does something with
the daleks where you you're listening
and you think oh this is going to matter
later on
so it's like for other companions
i i have a soft spot for amy
um
like in a way i kind of feel like
amy took the energy that i liked about
rose but dropped a lot of the things
about rose that i didn't care for so she
felt kind of refined in a way
um i love donna
uh oh yeah again that that was not just
a great comparing but a perfect pairing
with her and tenon and i not only love
bill i kind of kind of want to shout out
nardal a little bit too
oh yeah
guys like he's very clearly secondary in
terms of companion status compared to
bill but i i like
just how he how he plays in the mix in
terms of again just really fun mix of
personalities and that they're not all
the same and they are all very distinct
from each other in how they respond and
how they think and what they're going to
do
you know what not all is the person and
doctor who i feel
the way that we meet him feels so much
more like it actually feels to meet
people in real life than it than you
know an actual because you don't well i
mean you do sometimes but you very
rarely meet someone with an introduction
this is who they are hear some important
stuff about them uh get used to them
because they're going to be around for a
while you know you might do that if you
if you know that like you know like when
i
when i moved into student accommodation
i did that with my flatmates because i
was living with them and felt like i
shouldn't get to know them but you know
most people that you get to know
for me at least it's just sort of um
you know they're around in the distance
then they're around near it and then
they're around here and then they're
they're friends it's the kind of person
that you you can't tell you can't
remember the first time you met them
they were just around and i think that's
how it normally goes and they do that
with nadal because i couldn't tell i
could tell you the first story he was in
but
first time watching it i couldn't
funnily enough
both him and donna both of whom i like i
don't like their first appearance and i
don't mean i don't like the story like i
don't like them in their first
appearances no i understand that
completely
it but there's also something nice about
having a character grow on you over time
which is also part of what happened with
me with capaldi because i didn't
really start to connect with him until
series nine
and then fell in love with him in series
10 and like having that
build
can just feel
rewarding especially like
if you get to where you're like i love
this character then you look back and go
i don't even know what point that
happened but it's nice to be here
yeah exactly i do really feel that
writers underuse it under use the
development of background character to
side character
to
important character to main character
you know at least you know secondary
main character
um it's it's a rewarding journey to go
on
but you don't realize you're going on it
really
um
it's it's the kind of thing that only
works in longer form media or like
television or comics or or things like
that but yeah it is one of those things
that i i i do wish more
of these things took advantage of
because it's one of the potential
strengths of the medium
i do um
along for a bit more connective tissue
between areas of doctor who you know
when um
i'm an advocate for
martha jones appearing in the unit
stories in the muffat era
you know she's not a companion anymore
but she's still a character in the world
who does stuff
um yeah they have been doing very like
almost weirdly clean breaks between show
runner eras
and i mean i
to a certain extent i get it like to
some extent it almost feels like
professional courtesy because you're not
you're you're clearing the um the table
so that the the next person isn't
obligated to to keep working with the
same pieces that you were
yeah which so that part of it i get it
is odd to me how
reluctant
um
they tend to be to actually
make use of the old pieces
yeah
from the previous era like really the
only um
major thing that is cycled back around
has been
jack harkness
and then that lasted
well yeah that's that's become a whole
other thing now but
you know
it's it is strange that there are
theoretically all these things still in
play but that don't get picked back up
be and it's just really like well that
was davis's thing
yeah but it it was still good and
there's still more you could do with it
and i do struggle to see
i struggle to see why um
why writers
are afraid to generally
um
use the old thing but in a new capacity
you know you don't have to i feel like
seeing people going bring back martha
it's going to be like here's the martha
focal episode where it's like hey it's
martha
um and then we leave or it's going to be
she's the companion again i was like no
she could just be a character in the
story and i'd wanted to you know get her
moments with the doctor and get to
reconnect with him
uh or her i guess i was picturing it
with capaldi you don't have to do the
let's bring back martha episode to bring
back martha i would
i would have appreciated her being a
part of the unit crew that's just that's
my take i kind of wish
now they don't always work like this but
i kind of wish it worked the way that
comic books when they're doing it right
tend to work which is that there's all
these characters there's like a pool of
characters that can just show up yeah
because they're around doctor strange
can show up in a spider-man story why
because they both live in new york why
the heck not exactly
that's the
you don't always have to make a big deal
out of it and don't overdo it but like
these resources are available and
they could be used a lot more
yeah that that that's the kind of thing
is just you know
you know this character can show up
right you're like that's the just if
they would show up make them essentially
and that's that's sort of the that's
sort of the the um
the mindset i've taken to it with um i
don't know if you've if you're aware of
the streams i do with the
uh with chewbacc full oh yeah with the
the writing ones where we go we just
talk about what we would do with the
show
that's the attitude it's always
um and you know with just part of
established law as well not not just
characters specifically it's um
i i think we have you know we have
stories where i'm like
the ice warriors would work for this
they they're around let's use them when
you talk about the the stuff you do is
too bad for you know talking about
writing ideas and and
things to do with doctor you made me
remember an idea that i had ages ago
that i hadn't thought about in years
shoot but i kind of want and i'd like
this is not fleshed out at all but i
kind of want the show to do a villain
version of river song now i know she was
arguably villain-ish at some points but
what i mean by that is
i want the doctor to encounter someone
who hates him with the kind of hatred
that davros hates him
but the doctor doesn't know why because
this is the first time the doctor has
ever encountered this person you could
later backfill
with later interactions which could
potentially be really good character
moments for doctors at the time as they
encounter someone who they know will
someday hate them but is meeting them
then at a later time in the doctor's
life when this person hasn't developed
that hatred for them yet i think you
could get some really interesting stuff
out of that
yeah that's a sort of one of those um
hearing it sort of feels like one of
those why have they never done this
uh ideas
that that seems so natural for doctor
who
it like it is funny and like arguably
moffett overdid it but it is funny how
little
actual tinkering with the idea of time
travel other than using it to just be in
any setting
was in the show like it's weird to think
of how revolutionary blink felt
in terms of you know what it did with
time
considering the show had been around for
almost 50 years at that point and had
always been about time travel and how
infrequently it was anything other than
just a device to drop them off to drop
the doctor and companion off wherever
it's funny because what you're well
you're
pitching feels like such a rich premise
of
this could be a very serious drama or it
could be hilarious depending on how you
want to play it
it could easily go either way because it
could be it could be a case of somebody
who's really dangerous and the doctor
and like who knows the doctor but the
doctor does not know them and is
completely caught flat-footed by someone
who already knows them so well
or
it could be it could honestly almost be
like that scene from the
from the street fighter movie where
bison's like for you the first time we
met was the most important day of your
life but for me
it was tuesday
it could just not register for the
doctor so much and this whoever this is
just gets so infuriated by that
if they get more angry because he
doesn't recognize them
that's that's the
that's the comedy i have no further firm
ideas but i i'd forgotten that i had
that notion like a decade back
so that it's f it's fun to remember
ideas stuff i'm digging up from a decade
back because
i've
i wrote a lot of very bad stuff when i
was
about 10 years ago just just not not bad
for any you know
moral reason or any actual important
reason just i read it back
going i read back things that i wrote
two years ago and and want to disappear
into the floor so i guess well you know
i didn't i haven't written anything in a
while that's why that doesn't happen ah
i think i think we're kind of arriving
at a natural stopping point now hit like
here's gonna be the weird part where i
ask you if you have anything you want to
plug and i'm asking somebody with uh
with a footprint on this platform
about nine times bigger than mine but
where can people find your stuff i have
a channel called jxc and on it there's a
big video about doctor who this is a bit
controversial and there's going to be
another video about the controversy kind
of soon twitter and the rest of the
stuff i'm assuming the people can find
those
people they're all named after me
yeah so
go forth folks if for some bizarre
reason you watch my channel but have
never heard of jay before
i would encourage you to check out
what's out there and thank you again so
much for your time thanks for having me
on that's been lovely i want to thank
jay once more for giving time to this
project into this channel they were
wonderful to talk to i hope you'll check
out their stuff if you are not familiar
with their work but for right now
what's your favorite stuff of doctor who
favorite doctors favorite companions
favorite eras episodes elements aspects
villains what do you love
about this show
let's keep this one as positive as we
can
drop stuff down in the comments let's
talk about it you can support what i do
by checking out my patreon there are
rewards for every tier of support no big
pressure though because like share
subscribe also helps me out but don't
sweat that either because at the end of
the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]